Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Roberto Minelli
Sono Arturo Brachetti, un trasformista.
Un mestiere di difficile definizione,
anche perché la gente
mi ferma per la strada,
e mi dice: "Eh, ma tu sei
il trasformatore della tele?"
O peggio: "Ah, eccolo lì,
lo scambista di Internet."
Una signora a Napoli mi ha fermato
e fa: “Uè Brachetti,
mi faccia una trasfigurazione”.
Meraviglioso.
Insomma, io per mestiere mi declino
in decine, centinaia
di personaggi diversi,
pur rimanendo ovviamente
uguale a me stesso.
In un certo senso,
io potrei essere, come dire,
la parabola, la metafora teatrale
di uguale / disuguale.
Naturalmente, come dire,
nell'ambito della meraviglia
e della sorpresa.
Io a 11 anni ero un bambino
timidissimo, e soprattutto diverso.
Quindi, i miei genitori mi mettono
in collegio salesiano, in seminario,
in modo che possa diventare
uguale a tutti gli altri.
Ma per me non cambia niente:
la storia non cambia molto,
perché continuo a essere bullizzato.
Mi mettono, come al solito,
nel bidone dell'immondizia.
Vuoto, perché eravamo in un seminario,
e non nel Bronx - meno male.
E però conosco un prete
che faceva i giochi di prestigio,
e imparo da questo prete mago la magia.
Quindi, continuo a essere una schiappa
a ginnastica e a pallone;
però, quando prendo una carta
e indovino il tre di picche -
ah, come fa, ma è fantastico!
E quindi, scopro di avere
una specie di superpotere:
il potere di creare la meraviglia.
Continuo in questo viaggio
e quindi per anni, come dire,
mi invento anche dei sistemi
per cambiare i costumi, per trasformarmi.
E con un piccolo repertorio
di sei personaggi,
arrivo a Parigi, nel 1979,
per fare un'audizione.
E mi prendono subito:
ma non perché io sia
il più veloce di Parigi,
ma perché a Parigi mi dicono:
in questo momento, nel 1979,
tu sei l'unico al mondo
a fare questo tipo di spettacolo.
La cosa mi riempie di onore:
ero "il re della metamorfosi".
Ma insomma, non mi cambia la vita,
anche perché mi rendo conto
che intorno a me
ho dei colleghi straordinari.
Le persone che, magari,
nella vita normale sono ordinarie,
su un palcoscenico
diventano straordinarie.
Pensate che nello spettacolo
dove c'ero io c'era la Cariatis,
una trapezista che si lanciava
in "gran balant"
sulla testa degli spettatori,
appesa solamente per le caviglie,
senza rete e senza
un cordone di sicurezza,
unica al mondo.
Era un numero, veramente,
di grande tensione:
non solo la sua, ma anche
degli spettatori che stavano sotto,
devo dire la verità.
E conosco a Parigi un giornalista
che si chiama Jacques Bessis,
che è anche un esperto
di personaggi strampalati
del mondo dello spettacolo.
E così, sfogliando il suo book
di ricordi e di memorabilia teatrali,
scopro un personaggio che, come dire,
ha portato all'applauso
un gesto assolutamente normale,
addirittura triviale.
Sto parlando di Joseph Pujol, le pétomane:
oui, il petomane.
Allora, siamo a Marsiglia,
nel 1870, siamo al mare.
I nonni portano il nipotino al mare.
Joseph sta nuotando allegramente nel mare,
quando a un certo punto sente
un gran freddo alla pancia,
scappa alla riva
e si accorge di avere,
come dire, immagazzinato -
non dalla bocca, naturalmente -
una grande quantità d'acqua.
Allora prontamente se ne libera.
Tra l'altro è acqua pulita:
ma si spaventa moltissimo!
Quindi, impara a convivere
con questo problema.
Continua la vita,
diventa anche abbastanza popolare,
perché da militare ovviamente
lo chiamano per fare i gavettoni.
Però un commilitone,
un suo compagno, gli dice:
scusa, ma invece di tirare su dell'acqua,
perché non tiri su dell'aria?
Lui ci pensa: perché no?
Ci prova, e crea una specie
di camera d'aria,
di piccola cornamusa ad aria compressa
che poi, debitamente modulata,
può provocare delle pernacchiette musicali
assolutamente intonate e inodore.
Allora pensa: questo -
forse ho, come dire, una forma di talento!
E con questo si esercita,
e nel 1890 si presenta
a Parigi, al Moulin Rouge.
Al direttore Zittler, che gli dice:
- Ah, bene, lei è venuto
per un'audizione! - Mais oui.
- E mi hanno detto che lei
è musicista! - Oui, monsieur.
- Ha portato il suo strumento?
- Lo porto sempre con me.
Si mette sull'attenti,
e gli spara la Marsigliese.
Naturalmente avec son derrière,
ça va sans dire.
Ziller resta ovviamente allibito e dice:
non ho mai visto una cosa del genere,
lei è unico al mondo!
Io lo metto subito nello spettacolo.
E così la sera stessa
viene presentato come "Le pétomane".
Monsieur Pujol arriva in frac rosso,
con i baffetti all'insù,
perfettamente impomatati
e in perfetto francese, dice:
Bonsoir, messieurs-dames!
Questa sera assisterete
ad una séance de pétomanie.
Vedete, nel mio corpo abita
un'intera sezione di orchestra,
di strumenti musicali.
A fiato, naturellement.
Ecco il tenore -
il baritono -
il basso -
E ad ogni annuncio, ovviamente,
partiva la nota conseguente,
come voi potete ben immaginare.
Il pubblico rimane qualche secondo
pietrificato, bisogna dirlo.
Però lui incalza:
ecco il ruggito del leone -
mia suocera quando s'arrabbia -
il sospiro di una fanciulla,
la prima notte di matrimonio -
e il colpo di cannone di Waterloo -
Insomma, dopo qualche minuto
il Moulin Rouge si è trasformato
in un girone dantesco di ridarella.
La gente si scompiscia:
dopo pochi giorni vengono messi
degli infermieri lungo i corridoi
perché le signore
dell'aristocrazia parigina,
costrette nel loro corsetti,
svengono dal ridere.
È un successo micidiale.
E lui diventa lo showman
più pagato di Parigi,
più della Sarah Bernard,
che era la diva,
la grande attrice di quel tempo.
Fa una vita passando
da un successo all'altro,
e muore felicemente
dopo aver compiuto la sua missione.
Allora, perché ho parlato di Joseph Pujol?
Perché secondo me - parlo per assurdo -
ha trasformato platealmente
un rito, come dire, quotidiano, banale,
che facciamo tutti, spesso vergognandoci,
in una specie di superpotere.
Insomma, lui metteva in scena
un rituale catartico
che ridava, come dire, gloria e interesse
a una banalità, una debolezza
che facciamo tutti,
dal contadino al re,
dal camionista al Papa.
Però, vabbè, di Joseph Pujol
ne appare uno ogni 100 anni.
E allora, che dire
dell'altra miriade di supereroi
che popolano la nostra storia:
letterati, musicisti,
gente di scienza, gente dello sport?
Io non so parlare, di queste persone:
io parlo solo della gente
dello spettacolo.
Quindi perché non passare
alla prova del fuoco,
con la "donna ignifuga"?
Io l'ho conosciuta.
Sì, non è la signora Girardelli,
che nel 1700 si faceva mettere
in un forno a legna, insieme ad una pizza,
e ne usciva fuori
solo quando la pizza era cotta.
E non si chiamava neppure Margherita.
No, no, no, sto parlando
di una - come dire,
un’artista con cui io ho lavorato,
che era Kira von Biron,
"The Fireproof woman".
E nel 1981, io la presentavo
più o meno così:
[Tedesco:] E adesso,
signore e signori, Kira von Biron!
Le luci della scena si ammorzavano,
e da questa nebbia bluastra
arrivava questa donna felliniana,
assolutamente ricoperta di un mantello
super luccicante di lamette da barba,
con gli occhiali da saldatore
circondati da strass,
e un turbante in testa.
Si voltava, e il mantello esplodeva.
Boom!
Tutte le prime file
sentivano questo calore;
e rimanevano sorprese, anche spaventate.
Poi posava il mantello,
e rimaneva come dire, seminuda,
con un bikini di paccottiglia
e di ferro battuto.
Poi, ciò che la gente non sapeva
e che era tutto il suo corpo era ricoperto
da una garza color carne,
fatta di fulmicotone:
un materiale altamente infiammabile
e sicuramente, come dire, illegale.
A quel punto lei,
toccando dei contatti segreti,
poteva dar fuoco, che ne so,
al braccio destro, boom!;
al braccio sinistro, boom!
E poi, nel turbante,
aveva proprio la santabarbara:
un panettone esplosivo
composto da lycopodio, magnesio,
polvere pirica, cotone fulminante.
E il marito, con un lanciafiamme -
immaginate le leggi di sicurezza
di quei tempi: non erano quelle di adesso.
Con un lanciafiamme, le sparava
una palla di fuoco tra le ginocchia.
Per cui, a un certo punto, il corpo intero
diventava una torcia umana,
raggiungendo il turbante.
Fuochi d'artificio, scintille
e lapislazzuli, eccetera eccetera.
Si toglieva gli occhiali,
prendeva l'applauso
e finiva lì il suo numero.
Io, poi, le chiedevo nelle quinte:
ma scusa, ma tu non hai paura del fuoco?
E ovviamente lei diceva.
Io no!
Tu ricorda: non dovere
avere paura di fuoco.
Fuoco dover avere paura di te.
Vabbè, Kira, però insomma -
Comunque, questi sono
dei superpoteri da applauso,
da Guinness Book of Records, no?
Però, nella vita
di tutti i giorni, la nostra,
siamo circondati da gente
che ha superpoteri.
Nel campo, che ne so, dell'insegnamento;
le persone che salvano delle vite:
i medici, gli infermieri;
la gente che fa dei mestieri artigianali,
con delle minuzie e delle segreti
tramandati da millenni,
sono dei supereroi.
Certo, non sempre abbiamo
il superpotere che desideriamo.
Per esempio, se vi chiedo qual è
il superpotere di Uri Geller,
mi rispondete “piegare i cucchiaini
e le chiavi col pensiero”.
No, quella è una bufala.
Il vero superpotere di Uri Geller
è quello della comunicazione
e del marketing.
Lo ha ammesso lui stesso:
il resto è solo fuffa.
Quindi, i superpoteri
sono anche più umili, sono più quotidiani.
Saper cucinare;
saper allevare bene dei figli;
saper accudire gli altri;
saper parlare; saper ascoltare.
Ecco, saper ascoltare.
È un superpotere
incredibile, comunicativo.
Sapete che ho scoperto,
in una commedia del Québec,
che esiste un personaggio
nella cultura quebechese
che si chiama Maria dei Morti.
È una signora, una donna
che si chiama quando, nel villaggio,
c'era il moribondo
che stava per andarsene.
Si chiamava questa Maria,
i familiari uscivano,
e lei rimaneva sola con questo poveretto,
il quale si confidava con questa Maria,
le raccontava le peggio cose
della sua vita:
i desideri, i peccati, le gelosie,
gli amori corrisposti o no.
Poi, la Maria usciva dalla casa,
cercava un campo,
faceva un buco nella terra,
ci parlava, depositava
tutti questi segreti,
vomitava tutte queste parole,
che poi ricopriva con la terra,
e a quel punto il vecchio moriva
più leggero, più sereno.
Allora, magari lei era una contadina,
era una lavandaia del Paese.
Però non ditemi che questa
non è una forma di superpotere, no?
Quindi vorrei condividere con voi
questa sera una consapevolezza.
Che tra l'altro mi fa star bene,
e ci fa star bene:
che tutti quanti noi,
bene o male, nel nostro piccolo,
nel nostro mondo familiare,
condominiale, regionale, wikipediale,
siamo tutti supereroi.
Esserlo non è un'eccezione:
esserlo è la regola.
E tra l'altro, essendolo tutti
siamo tutti uguali nell'esserlo.
Ora, prima di lasciarvi,
vorrei presentarvi un ultimo personaggio
che ho interpretato io
in un mio spettacolo, molti anni fa,
ed è l'"uomo elefante".
"The Elephant Man"
è realmente esistito a Londra,
nella Londra del 1800.
Era un uomo, poveretto, affetto
da varie deformazioni, mostruoso,
presentato nelle fiere
e presentato nei mercati,
studiato dalla scienza.
E anche, come dire, vezzeggiato
e coccolato dall'aristocrazia.
Ora, nella mia versione onirica,
l'uomo elefante viene portato in scena
da suo padre padrone,
un domatore, un aguzzino
che lo obbliga a fare degli esercizi
quasi da animale da circo.
Ad un certo punto la musica cambiava,
e dalle mani dell'uomo elefante
cadevano dei pezzi di carta.
Allora prontamente il domatore,
il raccattino, le raccattava,
leggeva e realizzava:
"Poesie? Tu? Poesie? Ahahah!"
Le appallottolava, me le cacciava in bocca
e poi mi abbandonava,
umiliato per terra, esangue.
Quindi, a quel punto,
io sputavo questi scritti,
questi manoscritti,
e li leggevo.
E il testo diceva più o meno così:
"Ma che cos'è
il nostro bisogno più profondo?
Qual è il nostro desiderio,
fin dall'eternità?
Tra tante meraviglie,
sé stessi è essere una meraviglia.
Poiché nessuno,
è uguale ad un altro.
Noi abbiamo bisogno della meraviglia.
La meraviglia di poter essere invisibile.
La meraviglia della bellezza.
La meraviglia di poter essere amati.
La meraviglia di saper volare.
La meraviglia di poter essere,
per sempre, liberi."
E a quel punto, dalla crisalide
dell'uomo elefante
ne usciva un'anima leggera,
vestita di veli bianchi
che volava in un cielo stellato
con le note cantate da una voce bianca.
Mentre nella platea tutti quanti
si tenevano per mano, commossi.
Ecco, amici:
concludo dicendo che tutti noi -
tu, tu, insomma, tutti quanti -
siamo tutti uguali,
nell'essere una meraviglia unica.
(Applausi)